CARL SAFINA: All
right, well, we're
going to talk about basically
the subtitle of this book.
This book came out two days
ago, so it's brand new.
And we're going to start in
a kind of familiar place.
Many of us have animals at home,
and we've often asked ourselves
these questions, right?
How many people have
asked themselves
if their cat or dog
really loves them, or just
wants food, or whatever, right?
That's pretty common.
And we think, well,
it's impossible to know.
But is it really?
Is it really impossible
to know what's
going on in the mind and
the heart of our pets?
Well, in a way, no
and in a way, yes.
What's really going on in
those minds is the question.
Another question is-- it's
not showing up very well
there-- how are they like us?
But I don't like that
question so much.
It's an inescapable
question because they
are in many ways like us.
But when we say, how
are they like us,
we put the attention back on us.
And us is our favorite story.
We like to talk about ourselves.
And what we're really
supposed to be doing here
is asking, how are
they like us or not?
Who are we here on Earth
with is really the point.
And what is going on
in these minds that
are our co-voyagers
on planet Earth?
Is there any way to
get into the mind
of an elephant, for instance,
or any other kind of creature?
Well, I think there are actually
several really good ways
of seeing in.
You can look at their
brain and their mind.
You can look at their body, at
the logic of their behavior,
at their evolution.
So the first thing is if
we're interested in minds
is to know where is the mind?
In many parts of
human history, people
have thought the mind is
in the heart or the mind
is in the soul.
The mind is a
disembodied spirit that
is our eternal presence
in the universe, all
these different kinds of things.
So first of all,
where is the mind?
And a hint is that if
you have a heart surgery,
it's not going to
damage your mind.
But if you have brain surgery
and something goes wrong,
it's going to damage your mind.
Your mind comes from your brain.
The mind is in the brain.
And we might say, oh, we
have no idea if animals
are experiencing anything.
But we use their
experience all the time.
For instance, if we want
to know if cosmetics
are going to sting us, we test
them on the eyes of rabbits
to see if they sting the rabbit.
So if they sting the
rabbits, the rabbits
are having exactly
the same experience
of pain, the sensation of
stinging, as people have.
When dogs are
depressed, or if dogs
have obsessive-compulsive
disorder,
they respond to the same
drugs in the same way
that we give to people--
antidepressant drugs.
Why?
Because the part of the
brain that gets depressed
and the chemicals
that create depression
or obsessive-compulsive
disorders are exactly the same.
They're not experiencing
an analogous problem.
They're having the same
problem in the brain of a dog.
Or even as low as
down below vertebrates
on the evolutionary timescale,
or before vertebrates,
something like a
crayfish, you can
make crayfish develop
anxiety by giving them
little electrical
shocks and making
them feel nervous and tense.
And so they retreat
into their burrows.
They stop exploring.
They won't eat.
You give them the same
anti-anxiety drugs
that work on people,
the crayfish relaxes,
comes out of its burrow,
and starts exploring again.
So these are ways we
can manipulate minds
with different kinds
of tests and drugs
to see if they respond
the same way ours do.
And that's a good way in.
Now you can say, well,
we can see brains,
but we can't see the mind.
And that, in a sense, is
a fair enough statement.
I mean, it's true, right?
But I can't see your mind.
You can't see my mind.
It's always true.
But where is our mind from?
Where is the human mind from?
The human mind is from
the minds of non-humans
that were here before us.
When evolution created--
in a sense-- humanity,
humanity evolved from something.
We had to use the parts
that were already in stock
and make a few tweaks.
And the parts that were in stock
are the highly developed brains
of the other mammals
from which we evolved.
So if you look at a mouse brain,
and you look at a human brain,
it's a very similar, very
recognizable kind of thing.
The human brain looks different.
It's got lots of convolutions
in the forebrain.
That's where a lot
of thinking happens
in humans-- human thinking.
If you compare our brain
with a chimpanzee brain,
you see basically
that we are apes,
so it's not too surprising that
the human brain is basically
a very big chimpanzee brain.
So it's not logical to think
that the human brain only
does things that only
humans do and nothing that
happens in any other brain.
It's just completely illogical.
We're all very insecure,
we human beings.
We can soothe our
insecurity with the thought
that at least we have
the biggest brain, right?
Except, uh-oh, there's
a dolphin brand.
It's not only much bigger.
It has way more
convolutions than ours.
It's doing something
with all of those neurons
and all of those
networked connections.
We can see the
working of the mind
in the logic of behaviors
of other animals, the fact
that their responses and
emotions make sense to us.
We don't see-- well, we'll
go through a few, OK.
We say these albatrosses here,
they're dancing in courtship.
And why do we say they're
dancing in courtship?
Because that's a very
recognizable thing.
It happens at the same time
that humans dance in courtship.
It's something that we do,
pre-bonding and pre-mating--
same with them.
We look at elephants like this.
Now, elephants don't do
this if they're surrounded
by all kinds of dangers.
And they don't do this
if they're famished.
They do this if everything
is cool and nice,
and they're relaxed.
And the parents are still
a little bit on guard
while they let the babies
lie down and not worry
about anything.
That totally makes sense
to us, and it's totally
appropriate to the situation.
So we can tell by the logic of
their behavior, something about
what's going on in their minds.
They are protective
and parental,
like we are protective
whether they are humans or
elephants or mammals in water.
The differences between us
are mostly the outer contours
and a few internal tweaks.
So one analysis is only
humans have human skeletons.
But it's not true that
only humans have skeletons.
And only humans
have human minds,
but it's not true that
only humans have minds.
When help is needed,
help is provided.
They're not trying
to eat their baby.
They're trying to
help it to its feet.
I love this picture.
This is the cover of
the book, actually.
That's a newborn elephant that
has never stood up before.
And its mother and two
cousins are helping it
to its feet for the first time.
When animals are very
young, they're very curious.
They don't know what
things like egrets are.
They check everything
out, because they
have to learn what's
in their environment.
And many animals have to
learn just about everything.
Baby elephants don't even
know that lions are dangerous.
They have to be taught
by their parents
and by example that lions are
dangerous, that bees can sting
you, and these kinds of things.
But when we're young, we do
lots and lots of exploring.
And as we get a
little older, and we
know what's going on
in our environment,
and what we have to do, we tend
to be less playful than when
we were children.
We tend to do less exploring.
You can see that in others.
And when something goes
wrong, or something
might be dangerous, you
see a very different set
of behaviors.
And you see them
paying attention
in very different ways.
When it's time to
relax and have fun,
they relax, and they have fun.
Now, no one would
look at this and say,
I have no idea if the baby is
frightened out of its mind,
right?
It's not what you'd say.
You can see that
they're just having
a nice time in the water.
And that not all
of their behaviors
are driven by the need to
survive in the next minute,
that there are other things
that help us to survive.
A lot of these deep motivations
like love and like bonding,
these things, we don't just do
it in the minute it's needed.
We develop relationships
before these things
need to come into play.
So the love and bonding
of family members
is something that provides
ongoing benefits in many ways.
But we don't think,
OK, let's see,
I'm going to get ongoing
benefits in many ways,
so I better love my
siblings, and my parents,
and my family members.
That's just not how
our minds are equipped.
We just feel these
motivations, and then they
do what they are supposed to
do, what they're evolved to do.
Albatrosses have these bonds
and maintain these pair bonds
in ways that are a bit
unusual among birds, actually
even a bit unusual
among mammals.
Because their pair bonds
are very, very long-lasting.
They can live many
decades in the wild.
They mate with the
same mate every year.
And if a mate dies, it usually
takes them two or three
years to court and re-mate.
So you see the deep maintenance
of these bonds in them In a way
that I find quite touching
and really quite beautiful.
All right, there are other
things that are unexpected,
I guess.
Only unexpected
because our assumption
and what we've been
taught is that animals
have very, very simple
minds, and they're not
really aware of much.
And they just do things
without thinking about it,
without feeling about it.
But it turns out that if
you broadcast the recorded
conversations of tourists,
farmers who farm away
from where the elephants live,
and pastoralist herders who
walk around with spears and
get into trouble with elephants
around water holes, and fairly
frequently hurt the elephants,
that the elephants ignore the
conversations of the tourists.
They ignore the
conversations of the farmers.
And when they hear
the conversations
of the herders broadcast
out of hidden speakers,
they react with alarm.
The family bunches
up, and they run away.
They can actually
tell the difference
between human languages.
And they know which ones
are dangerous to them.
They react exactly the
same way to clothes
that are worn by those
three different groups, that
are placed on trails where
elephants can encounter them.
And that's been shown
with experiments.
So let's get a little bit
deeper into a question here
that is fundamental, which
is, can animals think?
Well, first of all, the
shortest answer is, of course.
Because humans are animals.
And human thinking
is animal thinking.
But another thing is, we
need much better definitions
of these words that
we tend to use.
So what do you mean by think
is the first question that you
should ask.
What do you mean by grieve?
What do you mean by empathy,
and all these questions that
are discussed with
different animals.
Thinking is the
processing of information
that's coming in through
the senses in ways
that help you make decisions.
So a jaguar that is
trying to sneak up
on a tapir or a peccary,
a wild pig, is thinking.
He's making calculations.
They know that the
intended prey will run away
if it detects them, and it
is trying to sneak up on it.
So that's thinking.
Somebody who is aiming an
arrow at a target is thinking.
And somebody who is entertaining
a proposal of marriage
should be thinking,
although perhaps not always.
Consciousness is another
thing that the definitions
are all over the map.
And some people think
that consciousness means
that you can plan years ahead.
And consciousness means
these complicated things
that-- I don't really think
that that's what it means.
Because if you are
given total anesthesia,
the difference between
conscious and not conscious
is induced by the anesthesia.
Consciousness means you're
experiencing sensations.
It's the thing that
feels like something.
That's what consciousness is.
So a motion sensor
senses, but it
doesn't experience sensations.
Dogs playing on the beach
experience sensations.
That's the difference between
an unconscious reaction
and consciousness.
I think consciousness comes
into play in evolution
at the level where animals need
to make decisions about things.
So if you simply cut your leg,
that's just a physical thing.
And lots of
unconscious processes
start happening immediately
and automatically.
The blood starts clotting.
The cells begin to heal the cut.
The immune system kicks
in to prevent infection.
So those are physical
things if you cut your leg.
But if your leg hurts
when you cut it,
then you know you're conscious.
So that's just consciousness.
There are, in a sense--
now this is just something
that I made up to try to
tease out different aspects
of consciousness--
these four interrelated
processes of consciousness.
We detect the world
through our senses.
We get information in.
Then if we think about
that information,
if we evaluate that
information, that is thinking.
If we just have an emotional
response to the information,
that's emotion.
If it changes our mood
to see something--
we may see something
that frightens us.
We may see something
that makes us jealous.
And then these moods
or these thoughts
give us motivations
and urges to act.
Empathy is often talked
about as something
that is uniquely human.
And when you are trying
to write a book about what
animals think and feel, you
read a lot about humans.
And you come across
constant claims
about what makes us human and
what things are uniquely human.
And most of them are wrong.
One of the things
that supposedly makes
us uniquely human is empathy.
Well, empathy is the ability
to feel with your companions
and to match their moods.
If you get scared, I get scared.
You feel and look sad,
I get sad or concerned.
That's empathy.
It means your mind
is able to match
the mood of your companions.
This is not something
new that just
started when people arrived,
and suddenly, here I
am, a human being,
suddenly, oh, empathy.
The oldest form of empathy
is something really important
and really basic, which is,
if you're with companions,
and one of them is suddenly
startled and frightened,
you cannot wait around saying,
wow, what got into you?
Why did you just run away?
Why is that?
Because the predator
will nail you.
So empathy and
the mind's ability
to match moods instantly
with companions
is something very, very old.
And the oldest
kind of empathy is
called contagious fear
or fear contagion.
There are different kinds
of empathetic responses.
Contagious yawning
is the weirdest one,
because I don't even
know what yawning is.
I don't think anybody even
knows what yawning is.
And yet, it's contagious.
It's very strange.
And I think you can tease out
different kinds of empathy
as well.
So there's basic empathy--
feeling with another.
You match moods.
A little bit away from that,
and a little distant from that
is what I call sympathy.
You say, oh, my
grandmother died.
I don't know your grandmother.
It doesn't make me sad to
know your grandmother died.
But it makes me a little sad to
know that that makes you sad.
So that's a kind of
empathy I call sympathy.
And then if you see
something happening,
and you are moved to
act, I call that kind
of empathy compassion.
It's like sympathy
and the urge to help.
And the motivation to
help and do something
is what I call compassion.
So you see somebody
who's homeless,
and you want to buy
them a sandwich.
Or you want to sign a
petition to save the whales,
or anything like that,
where your mood is affected,
and you are urged to act.
That I call compassion.
Human empathy is far,
far from perfect.
This thing, we like
to exalt ourselves
and say, oh, we're
the most empathetic.
Well, maybe and maybe
not all the time.
So on the left there is a
bunch of dogs bundled up
in a cage for a dog-eating
festival in China recently.
And on the right-- I'm not sure
how well you can see that--
but that is a man in
a cage in Indonesia.
He is a Burmese man.
He is a slave.
This was a picture
taken this past March
when hundreds of Burmese
slaves were found being forced
to work on Thai fishing boats.
Buy shrimp that has been
wild-caught in Thailand,
chances are pretty good
that slaves have caught it,
because human empathy is not
really so great all the time.
A thing that I
find interesting is
that people who know essentially
nothing about the science
of animal behavior
know one thing,
and that is, you should
never use anthropomorphism.
Everybody knows this tricky
word, anthropomorphism,
which is projecting human
thoughts and emotions.
In the behavioral sciences,
doing such a thing,
and attributing human thoughts
and emotions to animals,
has been for a few decades,
a total career killer.
It's absolutely not
allowed in academia.
And journalists write
about this all the time.
And journalists try to be
very professional by saying,
oh, we can't
anthropomorphize the animals.
But since their minds
and their imperatives
are very similar to ours because
we came from what they have,
I think it's actually a
very helpful first step.
And then if you know a little
bit something about animals,
you're not likely to
make many mistakes.
For instance,
these two elephants
are consorting, right?
That's a male on the right
and a female on the left.
Actually, the female had
a baby just as the book
was going to the publisher.
And if you saw them, and
you were really projecting,
you might say, oh, look at them.
They're in love.
But if you talk to any
elephant researcher,
it's well-known that
elephants actually
don't have romantic love.
They do find sex very exciting,
and that is very obvious.
This one in the front has
just made it and run back
to her family.
Her facial glands-- they
have glands on their faces,
kind of like we have
glands in our armpits.
And when they get very emotional
about anything, when they're
happy or frightened, at
a heightened emotion,
those glands stream.
So she's just made it.
Her family is reassuring her.
And they're sniffing her,
and they're checking her out.
But there's no pair bond
between her and the male.
The male provides
no parental care.
So it is obvious that they
do find sex thrilling,
but sex for them is not always
coupled with romantic love.
I don't know if that sounds
familiar to any of you,
but I'm not going to ask, OK?
So the main thing that
evolution shows is that life
is on one continuum.
There are no sharp breaks.
Everything that
we see in people,
we see the beginnings
of in other animals.
Some things that we
see in people, we
see other animals that have
it far, far better developed.
Many other animals have
superhuman response times,
superhuman strength,
superhuman homing abilities,
things like that that
we just don't have.
And we have some things
that they don't have.
But it's all on a continuum.
All the way back to
worms, the chemicals
that worms make that
create mood and motivation
are some of the same
chemicals that create mood
and motivation in human brains.
Even plants make some
of those chemicals.
And it's unclear whether
any plants actually
have any sensations at all.
They don't have a nervous
system like animals do,
so there's some
speculation on that.
And many people say no, and
some people say, yes, probably.
But especially among animals,
there are no sharp breaks.
So we recognize when an animal
looks hungry or thirsty,
we say, oh, it's hungry
and thirsty or it's tired.
And then when they're
happy, we say, oh, we
have no way of knowing.
This is the science
of animal behavior.
And actually, that is
just not scientific.
It's really a bias.
So denying that they have
thoughts and feelings
helps us to retell our
own favorite story.
What is our favorite
story, do you think?
Who wants to take
a guess at this?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Animals are
here for us to use.
CARL SAFINA: That's one
of our main stories.
It's not our favorite story
that I was thinking of.
AUDIENCE: We're the endpoint
and the goal of evolution.
CARL SAFINA: We're the
endpoint of evolution,
the goal of evolution.
And we are absolutely special
and absolutely different
and better than everything else.
And part of the reason
we tell ourselves
that story is so we can think
that all animals are here
for us to use, which
makes it easier
to make decisions about what
we're going to do to them.
So those two things combined,
I think, help reinforce us.
It just makes it easier
for us to continue to think
and believe those things.
What about love?
Do animals feel love?
This is a baby humpback
whale, a nursing age humpback
whale that washed up in East
Hampton a couple of summers
ago.
And the night that
that whale washed up,
the lighthouse
keeper at Montauk,
15 miles away,
said that she heard
incredibly mournful
sounding whale sounds coming
from the ocean all night.
And she said, nobody would
believe me if I told you that.
But I mean, she is
the lighthouse keeper
at Montauk Point.
So I do believe her.
It sounded like there
was a whale out there
looking for its lost baby.
So what do we mean
by this word love?
Here's another definitional
problem for us, right?
Many of us would say
that we love our parents.
We would say that we
love our children.
We also say we love that movie.
We love ice cream.
We love having a glass
of wine before bed.
Some people love fighting.
So if we use that
word, that word that's
so important, if we
use that word to cover
all kinds of things that we
like-- I love ice cream-- then
it is clear and inescapable
that animals love.
Animals that care for one
another, your pets that
have a relationship with you
and seek contact and comfort
from you, that that is love.
It may not be exactly
the same kind of love
that you feel when
you talk about how
you love your spouse, or
your lover, or your children.
But the way you love
your spouse is not
the same exact way that your
spouse loves you, right?
So love is not all one thing.
And I think we can safely
say that animals do often--
those animals that
really experience
these social bonds and these
protective bonds-- experience
love.
Now, this guy here, that
elephant on the right, his name
is Philo.
And he's a 15-year-old
juvenile male in Kenya.
And that's the last
photograph taken of him,
because four days
later, that was him
on the lower right with a
bullet hole in his brain.
Elephants are maybe the most
famous animals with regard
to their responsive grief.
When an elephant goes down,
the family always rushes to it
and tries to lift it and aid it.
And if an elephant
dies, family and friends
hang around, often for days,
and will revisit the bones,
often for years.
And when they revisit
the bones, they usually
touch the parts that
they knew best in life--
the tusks, if there are
any tusks left, the teeth.
Because when elephants greet,
they usually greet in a trunk
to mouth greeting.
It's kind of a combination
handshake, hug, and kiss
that they do with their trunk.
Grief is something that
I've noticed and read about,
not only in elephants,
where it's really
pretty well-known and
well-documented, but in wolves.
A researcher told me
about a female wolf
whose mate had died.
And she had pups that
were less than a year old.
And she immediately left.
She left her pups.
It was winter.
She went on a two-week trip
on the highest, bleakest parts
of Yellowstone
National Park, where
there were no tracks of prey.
There was nothing
she was doing there.
She was just wandering,
kind of aimlessly.
And two weeks later,
she came back,
and she rejoined those pups.
This sounds silly, but it
was very interesting to me.
I had a pair of ducks, and
these ducks were inseparable.
We had two ducks
and four chickens.
They were inseparable.
And the drake died.
And the female spent weeks
wandering around the yard,
quacking, and
calling, and looking,
and calling, and looking.
And you could
really see that she
was taking a lot of time
out of her normal routine.
It wasn't her normal
routine at all.
She wasn't eating
in the same way.
She wasn't going
to the same spots
and resting in the same way.
And a woman named
Barbara J. King,
who wrote a book
on grief, provided
I think a very helpful
definition of that word, which
is that grief happens
when a companion is lost,
and the individuals who have
lost the companion change
their routine.
They go off their feed.
They look around.
They're trying to find the
companion, that that's grief.
And that's pretty
much what we do.
And our grief takes
different forms also.
For some of us, we might
miss a day or two of work,
and then we're
kind of back to it.
Go to the wake and come back.
And others of us,
our entire lives
are upended and never
really the same.
It's similar to other families
of animals that I've seen,
families of wolves, and
families of elephants,
where if something happens
to the adults, they get shot.
They die really prematurely.
The whole trajectory of the
family is changed forever.
We don't really tend
to know these things
because watching animals and
knowing them is very, very new.
The first people who ever
systematically watched
wild animal behavior are
still alive-- Jane Goodall,
and Cynthia Moss, and
one or two other people
who've been doing that for
about 40 years, since the 1960s.
That's as far back as we
go to understand anything
about the family
lives of individuals.
And they can tell
you, I've known
that elephant for 40 years.
I knew who her mother was.
I know what happened
to her sisters,
I know what she did
during the last drought
to keep the family alive.
It's really incredible,
but it's not
something that has
seeped deep down
into general human knowledge.
All right, this I mentioned.
There's a lot of
grief in the world
in and around
elephants nowadays.
That woman is Daphne
Sheldrick, and she
runs the very famous elephant
orphanage in Nairobi, Kenya.
Kenya is only one
country in Africa,
and that's only one orphanage.
And they're constantly
besieged right now
by orphans because there's
this war against elephants,
really, going on.
I mean, it's basically an
extermination campaign going on
because of how out
of control the ivory
market has gotten again.
But she will tell you, as she
told me, that an elephant can
actually die of grief.
And many of these
young elephants
who've watched their families
in the turmoil of getting
demolished, come in
very, very traumatized
and take many months
to settle down,
and then years to try
to repatriate them
in these not very natural
artificial families
that they are creating
back in the wild.
I had the extreme
good fortune of being
allowed to go out with them
on these walks every day.
They take these little
orphan baby elephants,
let them out of their
pens in the morning.
They know the keepers very well.
They bond with each other and
with the keepers, and they
walk around.
And in a few minutes,
you're in the bush.
You can't see them
most of the time.
You can kind of hear them.
If the keeper wants them
to go somewhere else,
we're going to go down this
hill now, they just call.
All the babies come
out of the bush.
They follow them down.
And it's really moving to
see and feel the capacity
that these creatures have.
And just because we're
just discovering it,
doesn't at all mean it's new.
It's not at all new.
It's many, many
millions of years old.
And it's the lives
that they have
and the vivid lives
that they lead.
And as I mentioned, nowadays,
all these elephants literally
have a price on their head.
It's very, very remarkable
that this guy-- his name
is Tim-- that he is still alive.
Around Roman times,
when Europeans first
took an interest
in ivory, elephants
lived everywhere from
the Mediterranean
to the bottom of the
Cape of Good Hope,
except for the bleakest
parts of the Sahara Desert.
The African elephant
covered all of Africa.
And you can see how its
range has shrunken since 1980
and is just fracturing
into splinters now.
That is the geography
of an animal
that we are driving
to total extinction.
In another part of my
travels for the book,
I went to Yellowstone
Park to look at wolves.
Wolves are really, really
incredible animals.
They're very, very much like us.
They live in family groups
with a breeding pair
and the youngsters of
several different ages,
usually one to three years old.
And then after
that, the youngsters
leave and try to find and
establish their own packs.
These two adults
from one of the main
packs-- this one was a
really, really famous wolf.
Lots and lots of people watched
her and photographed her.
And she was very well-known.
They left the park and were
almost immediately shot.
And their whole family
kind of fell apart.
The alpha male was
left with no mate.
That guy on the top
right was his brother.
Basically, his
hunting companions
and the ones who held down
the territory were gone.
He had no mate.
Two new males came in.
He lost his family, basically.
And then this daughter, who
was the most precocious one
in the pack, got ganged
up on by these two
sisters, who wanted to be the
mates of the two new males.
And they forcibly ejected
her from her own family
permanently and wouldn't
let her back in.
Now, I knew that
wolves live in packs.
And I knew that the packs
were families-- that I knew.
And I knew that, in that
way, they were a lot like us.
But what I had no idea
about was the turmoil
that would happen in the
family when something happened
to the parents-- the coalitions,
the vendettas, the politics.
It was really all too human.
So that one that got run out,
she had to eventually leave
the park, and she got shot.
And this guy, who
was the alpha male,
the breeding male
that lost everything--
he lost his family, he lost his
mate, he lost his territory,
and it was winter, and he was
not young-- he, incredibly
enough, against all
odds, he is still alive.
That's him sitting on a rock.
He had just been calling
to another female
that he was trying to
draw out of another pack
to try to take her as his
mate and start a new pack.
So anyway, that was him when I
was there, and this is him now.
And he's still
alive, which I think
is quite remark-- it
makes me feel really good
that he survived.
We like survival stories.
What do you think that is?
AUDIENCE: A dog?
CARL SAFINA: You
think it's a dog.
Who thinks it's a dog?
Who thinks it's a wolf?
All right some
dogs, some wolves.
OK.
Well, it's a full-blooded wolf.
And an interesting
thing about dogs
is that before people
understood evolution,
but they started applying
Latin names to animals,
the dogs were called Canis
familiaris, the familiar canid.
And wolves were Canis lupus.
But now we know enough
about their genetics
to realize that dogs are
so minutely differentiated
from their wolf ancestors,
that their Latin name
got changed back to wolf.
So the dog's Latin name is
now Canis lupus-- wolf--
familiaris.
So it's a wolf,
but it's our wolf.
Domestication doesn't mean a
tame, wild animal in captivity.
It means an animal or a
plant genetically changed
from its wild type.
Almost all animals
that are domesticated
are domesticated
for tameness first.
And it turns out, weirdly,
that the same genes that
make animals tame
and tractable also
create certain similar
physical changes.
They create floppy ears,
blotchy-colored coats,
coats of different
textures, curled
tails, passive personalities.
The same genes, not a
suite of different genes.
So dogs show a lot of that.
Farm animals show a lot of that.
Who else shows some of that?
AUDIENCE: Foxes.
CARL SAFINA: Foxes.
OK.
Well, that gets to
an interesting story,
which is that most
of this stuff that's
known about what's called
domestication syndrome
is known because of a
40-year experiment with foxes
done in Russia, where
they selected them only
for tameness.
The ones that were tame and
friendly, they let breed.
And the ones that weren't,
they basically killed.
After a few generations,
they got tame foxes
that wag their tails,
seek their humans,
and have floppy ears, blotchy
coats, and curly tails.
These are hand raised wolves.
They act remarkably like dogs.
They have not been bred for
10,000 years around people.
These are our wolves at
home, our two wolves.
They're not fighting,
they're playing.
They're good friends.
Other aspects of domestication
include a lot of sex
outside the breeding
season that does not
result in offspring, passive
behavior, conformity,
reduced brain size, and neoteny.
Neoteny means you carry juvenile
traits way into maturity,
right?
That's what it means.
So, can anybody think
of any other animal
that does all of this?
AUDIENCE: Humans?
CARL SAFINA: Humans.
Right, humans.
Now, why would humans
have those traits?
If you look at the bottom
thing there, farm animals,
we brought animals onto farms
to live a passive, settled
crowded life, and be able to
conform and get used to it
and do OK there.
And we inadvertently had to
do exactly the same thing
to ourselves.
So in the process of
domesticating animals,
we slightly, at least,
domesticated ourselves.
We are also like
big juveniles, many
of us, as you can clearly
see by all the themed
sections of this building.
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
In the interest of time,
and because we stopped late,
I think I'm going to stop there.
Because I really want to
have some discussion and some
questions.
So I think I said
we stopped late.
We started late.
So I'm going to just
stop right there.
And anybody have any
questions about animals?
Animal thinking,
animal emotions,
objections to anything I said?
We can just take it all on.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I wanted to know your
opinion about studies where
scientists assess
animal intelligence
and give equivalents,
like, oh, a dog's
equivalent to a three-year-old,
like an octopus is
equivalent to an eight-year-old.
What's your opinion on that?
CARL SAFINA: Yeah, what's
my opinion of studies
that equate the
intelligence of animals
with humans at certain ages.
Well, in a way,
they're interesting.
And in a way, they're
the wrong question.
And I came to see that it's
the wrong question because I
asked Cynthia Moss, who
has been studying elephants
for 40 years.
This, I thought, was
the big question.
I said, what has watching
elephants for 40 years taught
you about human nature?
And I thought that was
a really deep question,
and it was going to be so
interesting to talk about.
And she said, I'm not
really interested in that.
I'm interested in elephants.
I want to learn about elephants.
Comparing an elephant or a
raven's performance on a puzzle
to a human toddler doesn't
interest me at all.
And I was very
taken aback by that.
I also felt kind of stupid
for asking that question,
considering her response.
And I thought about that.
It took me a few days for me to
really do a full mental reset
on that question.
The problem with
comparing a raven
to a toddler or
the communication
ability of a chimpanzee
to a small child
is not that it
tells you nothing,
but that it doesn't
ask the question that
lets you get the full answer.
It's always about us.
Tell me, what could you learn
about the ability of a raven
to solve a puzzle by
comparing it with a child?
You learn, again,
that humans are better
at solving puzzles than ravens.
But you don't really
learn a lot about what
ravens do in their
complicated, vivid lives
that they lead among their
friends and their rivals
in familiar territories,
how they seek status, how
their status gets deposed over
the course of their life, how
their life follows
the arc of a career.
You don't learn any
of that about them
by comparing them
to a three-year-old.
So the whole question
of what intelligence
is, is a very
fraught definitional
question anyway,
because there are just
different kinds of capacities.
And usually with
humans, we think
of intelligence, more
or less, as the ability
to solve novel problems.
And many humans have
a pretty good ability
to solve novel problems.
But who was more intelligent,
Henry Ford or Pablo Picasso?
Does intelligence mean
anything at most levels
of performance and existence?
And many animals do things
that we can't do at all.
But if we can do anything,
we give ourselves
an enormous amount of credit.
Like we have the
ability to learn music,
for instance, just to
think of one thing off
the top of my head.
We can learn music, and we can
learn how to play instruments
that other people have invented
for us to play and make music.
We just have a musical ability.
We don't have such a
great homing ability.
We can't home for
thousands of miles
across open ocean just
based on our perception
of the Earth's magnetic
field, and things like that.
So fish and birds that can do
that, we just discount that.
We don't say, oh, my god,
they're brilliant at this.
They are geniuses
compared to us.
We never say that.
We just say, oh, who cares?
Well, we can play
an instrument, or we
can solve a problem,
or something like that.
There have been experiments
done with ravens,
with certain kinds of puzzles,
where the ravens can figure it
out.
And dogs and toddlers are left,
in the words of one researcher,
"not even realizing there
was a puzzle to solve."
So to me, it just isn't
really all about us,
and it's not all about now.
And we have to get
outside of ourselves.
Every time, we're always
looking at the world
through our eyes,
which of course is
the normal starting place.
But when you look
from the inside out,
you only can see an
inside out world.
When you can get
outside yourself,
like the famous iconic
first photograph
of Earth from space orbit, you
get a different perspective.
And what I've really tried to
do in my work, in my thinking,
and this book is get
outside of ourselves
and look at humans
in perspective,
in the whole sweep of life, and
the history of life on Earth,
and the whole family of living
things that are here with us.
Because there's a lot at stake.
And not only is there
a need, I think,
to show what is at
stake as we take
more and more from
the rest of the world,
but I wanted to show
also who is at stake.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do you think animals,
like a dog sitting next
to a windowsill, can daydream
and have thoughts unassociated
to what they see?
CARL SAFINA: Do I
think animals have
daydreams and thoughts
unassociated from what
they're actually seeing?
Yeah, sometimes they do.
And I see that in my own dogs.
Sometimes my dogs
might be lying around.
And then they'll
suddenly get up,
and they'll run outside
to go and check and see
if there are any squirrels
at the bird feeder.
Because they love
chasing swirls around.
So things occur to them.
Sometimes they get up
and they come over.
If I'm writing, and the
dog is napping nicely,
they'll sometimes wake up,
especially one of them.
She'll wake up, she'll
come, and she'll just
start hitting me with her paw.
And the door is open.
So what does she want?
She's just thought that she
wants me to go out with her.
She wants to maybe go for a run.
She's trying to get me to engage
with her, because these things
cross her mind.
If she could never think
about going for a run
unless we were
going for a run, she
wouldn't be coming and
bothering me to go for a run.
Well, yeah, we'll
just leave it at that.
I can tell you other stories,
but it's more or less
the same point.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So outside
of humans as animals,
did you observe that some
of these other animals,
the same species, would develop
different cultures depending
on where they were?
CARL SAFINA: Some animals do
develop different cultures
depending on where they were.
A couple of the most notable are
killer whales and chimpanzees.
Chimpanzees make simple tools.
But the tools they
make are different
in different populations
of chimpanzees.
So there are some chimpanzees
that fish for termites
by using twigs and
pieces of grass.
They stick it in
the termite hole,
and the termites bite it
to try to defend the hole.
And then they pull
it out, and then they
eat the termites, right?
Some of the chimpanzees
that do that live in
places where there are really
hard nuts, and there are rocks.
But they have never
figured out that you
can use rocks to crack nuts.
But there are other
chimpanzees that
use rocks to crack
nuts all the time
and actually use
rocks on another rock
like an anvil to crack nuts.
Those ones that have figured
that out have an advantage.
They get more calories because
they have a whole other food
source that's available to them.
So they learn it
from one another.
That's the definition
of culture.
They're not born that way.
They learn from one another.
But the other population
doesn't have it yet.
So when you think
about humans, you
have to try to think of before
globalization of any kind,
before ships got
all around anyplace.
Human cultures were often
very, very different
from one another.
The technologies were
often very, very different
from one another.
So you see the inkling
of that in chimpanzees
with simple tools.
And those chimps have
stone and anvils.
And some of them have
wooden clubs and anvils.
That's not terribly dissimilar
to the most advanced tools
that many people had until
recently, not that long ago,
where there are many cultures
where the most advanced tool
was a bow and arrow.
They had no machine of any kind.
They had nothing that
had an internal moving
part of any kind.
They mostly had digging
sticks, and they had pounders,
and they had spears,
and bows, and arrows.
So anyway, that's chimpanzees.
And with killer whales,
the cultural differences
are strange.
One is they have vocal
cultural differences.
But the strange part is
that different groups have
some of the same calls, some
calls specific to their group
only.
Other groups they
socialize with do not
pick up on the calls
of that other group.
It helps to define
which group is which.
And even though they
mingle, and even though they
hear each other, they
don't copy all of those
sounds that clearly
those ones in the groups
learn from the other ones.
And some of the groups mingle.
And some of the groups get close
to each other and never meet.
and never mingle,
like ethnic groups
that don't like each
other for some reason.
And it's not explained,
but it's a weird thing.
And the closest thing to
what those killer whales do
is humans, where there
are different tribes that
won't mix even though
we're all exactly
the same, except for
small cultural or language
differences.
It's mostly where you're
born is what it is.
And with those
killer whales, it's
mostly where they're born,
what pod they're born into.
And they carry that identity,
and they won't mix with others.
And it's very odd.
Any other questions?
Richard.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
By the way, that's similar
to certain jungle birds.
And they'll go into
these big, mixed flocks.
And they will pay
attention to warning cries
of predators from another
species or another group.
And but then they will
segregate out again,
so it's very similar.
The question I want
to ask you is this.
You say you kept wolves.
I didn't know that
you kept wolves.
CARL SAFINA: What?
AUDIENCE: Wolves.
CARL SAFINA: I didn't
keep wolves myself.
No, no, I have dogs.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
Well OK, I have dogs.
And one thing that
I've read recently
is that one of the innate
differences-- and I'm
asking you if you know
whether this is true or not--
between dogs and wolves is
that dogs will follow a human's
gaze looking at something.
CARL SAFINA: Yes.
And right, and you're going to
say, and wolves don't, right?
MALE SPEAKER: And wolves don't.
CARL SAFINA: That's baloney.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
CARL SAFINA: And here's
why it's baloney.
And here's why a lot of the
laboratory studies of animals
and animal behavior are
too simplistic to capture
what's there.
Dogs were tested to follow
pointing with their owners,
the people they knew the best.
So you take your dog into a lab.
And they say, OK, you stand
there, and put the dog there.
OK, sit.
OK, ready, go.
Now, point.
OK, so the owner points.
The dog looks.
Then they take
wolves with humans
that they don't know it all.
They put them behind a chain
link fence because, oh, my god,
they're wolves.
And they point.
And a wolf behind a chain link
fence surrounded by strangers
doesn't look where the
other person is pointing.
But it turns out
that when you take
hand raised wolves
with familiar people,
without a chain link fence
between them, and you point,
the wolves perform
as well or better
than the dogs with no training.
Because they are
incredibly keyed into one
another in their social groups.
When a wolf goes like
that, all the other wolves
have to see what's
interesting over there.
Are we about to hunt?
Did they just see something?
What's going on?
AUDIENCE: Well, the claim was
that that they did not do that.
CARL SAFINA: The
claim is disproven.
MALE SPEAKER: Good.
CARL SAFINA: Put a
big X on that claim.
One more question, yes.
AUDIENCE: It's actually
related to that.
You're talking-- there's
blurb about your book
where you describe these
cooperative hunting behaviors,
like whales knocking a seal
off an ice floe and lions
attacking in wings.
How does that
communication work?
Do we know about
how they coordinate
those kind of things?
CARL SAFINA: In
some cases, we know.
And I would say in most
cases we pretty much know.
And that is, they're very,
very tuned into one another.
So you mentioned the
killer whales that
wash the seals off the ice.
What was the other thing
that you mentioned?
AUDIENCE: The lions.
CARL SAFINA: The lions, right.
So I actually saw some of
the thing with the lions.
And I didn't see the behavior
develop because they knew
exactly what they were doing.
But I saw them do it.
So what I saw was
lions are sleeping.
We're watching these lions.
We were watching
those particular lions
because that particular
pride had a habit of hunting
during daylight,
which is unusual.
So we went to watch and
see if they were going
to do something really cool.
And they were sleeping,
and then they woke up.
And when they woke
up, they got up
and they did a big rally with
each other, a big greeting.
They're all licking
each other's faces,
and they're all smushing their
faces together and everything.
And then they're
going to go hunt.
Now, first of all, you don't
need to lick somebody's face
in order to go hunting, right?
But they do that.
Why do they do that?
Because that's a reaffirmation.
It's just like we wake up
and we say good morning
to everybody in our family.
It's a reaffirmation.
We're here.
We know who we are.
We're together.
This is our group identity.
So that thing, reestablished
in the course of their day,
they then leave the
area where they were all
lying around sleeping.
And they leave together,
because that greeting
helped coordinate them.
OK, we're all up now?
OK, let's go.
They go to a hill.
Obviously, they know
exactly what hill
they're going to because
they just went there.
They just go to the hill.
And then they walk along
the crest of the hill.
One of them sits down,
and the others keep going.
And why did that lion just sit
down and the other keep going?
A second lion sits down,
and the rest keep going.
A third lion sits.
A fourth lion sits,
until there is a picket
fence of yellow lions
in the yellow grass
at the crest of this hill.
And one lion walks
toward the zebras that
are about a quarter mile away.
And the plan is-- which
they've obviously done before
and they knew exactly
what they were
doing-- we'll all wait here.
You go chase the
zebras up the hill.
The zebras were no fools.
They detected the
lion that was coming,
and they spooked and
went farther away.
So what I saw was really,
really interesting,
It wasn't incredibly dramatic
because the hunt really
didn't engage.
As far as the killer
whales, they fan out,
and they're looking in the
pack ice, those ones that
wash the seals off.
They fan out, and they're
looking around the pack ice.
They can hear each other a
long distance underwater,
and they call a lot.
They recognize each
other's voices,
like you recognize
people on the telephone.
They know who's
calling underwater.
And they're looking
mostly for Weddell seals.
It's a certain kind of seal
that they particularly like.
So if they're not
food stressed, they're
looking for Weddell seals.
One of them finds
a Weddell seal.
It doesn't immediately try
to attack the Weddell seal.
It backs off and calls until
the rest of the group which
might, in that case, be
three or four individuals,
they all come together.
They swim away from the ice.
And then on some signal, either
vocal or visual behavioral,
it's OK, now, and
then they all go.
And they all pump their
tails like this in unison,
and that creates a big moving
wave right above the tails.
And they go right
to the ice, and then
they just dive under the ice.
That wave breaks over the ice.
It washes the seal off, and
then they get the seal that way.
And killer whales, more than
any other animal in the world,
they share their kills.
They share a really high
percentage of their kills.
So it's a really, really
cooperative hunting thing.
I mean, wolves share the kills
too but in a more passive way.
The thing is down,
and it's just there,
and they all eat from it.
But the whales actually pull
it apart and bring pieces
and give to one another.
Because they're in a more
fluid environment like that.
So I'm happy to stay
a few more minutes.
I don't want to keep
you too much longer,
because we did start late.
And I want to thank you very,
very much for coming out.
Obviously, we've got
some books in the back.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]